more and more info is coming out about
the Game of Thrones prequel let's jump
right in and talk it out are we okay
with this
joining me is my good friend and Game of
Thrones extraordinaire ken Knapp sock
I'm so happy to be I'm so happy to have
them in this house I'm usually in your
house yes it's a good role reversal
welcome to Castle black and ETS own
queen of dragons also my good friend
Leon Aguilera - thank you so much for
having me in this outsider chat all
about the show yeah let's uh let's dive
right in so the show is set thousands of
years before the events of Game of
Thrones and chronicles the world's
descent from the Golden Age of Heroes
into its darkest hour this tells us so
little it's beautifully big but also
kind of a lot how do you guys feel about
the time period that the prequel is
taking place I love this era there's so
much to mine because there's so little
we know that you keep talking about here
and there you know it's built in to Game
of Thrones george RR martin loves
playing around with oh you like that
prophecy it can go fifteen different
ways yeah you like The Histories we
don't really know rocks told us the
story now we get to make it up so I
think that's a fascinating choice from
HBO I'm all for the fact that it is a
prequel because george RR martin just
released his new prequel book still
waiting on that last game of thrones
book but okay his new brickle book fire
and blood which kind of tells those
thousands of years that have been
missing about the Targaryen rule and
conquering of the Seven Kingdoms so if
that is what we're gonna be seeing in
this new prequel series I'm all for it
yeah I love that idea because the Age of
Heroes we know maybe hey maybe the
Targaryens of dragons aren't there but
people are gonna want to see things they
know and because they can tie in a we
got the east you don't know what
happened you could have a dragon you you
could have the Targaryen over there
going we're kind of bored you want to go
conquer something there's a whole just a
minefield of information to that I'm all
for finding out more about the
characters that we keep hearing little
nuggets of bran the Builder who
eventually built the Great Wall of
Westeros to block out the White Walkers
law in the clever who kind of started
the lannister lineage yeah I want to
meet these characters there's a lot
there I think you took the Atlantic
llevaron and him kicking out the cast
release by basically haunting their
castle which he's started the house
Lannister but I think he's more Tyrion
than he is seriously Tywin or Jaime he's
a trickster I like that kind of
connection yeah I do like it that it's
these little nuggets that we kind of
hear about and now we get to go back and
see this story but is this the story
that you guys would have wanted to see
had you been able to pick your own Game
of Thrones prequel because for me when
they say that the first thing that comes
up is is Robert's rebellion interesting
choice well you know there are still
four other successor shows in the works
at Game of Thrones there was initially
five but one of them has been axed so
this is only just one of the successor
shows as george RR martin likes to put
it but i feel like we could see that
entirely too i feel like this is turning
into a whole Star Wars universe
I won't Kay with that there you're
Robert's rebellion the dance of dragons
almost kind of Targaryen Civil Wars
there's a lot of great stuff but I think
I think on about we were talking about
with with people wanted something new
but tied to something they know yeah
there's a lot of these houses whether
the beginning or not their names they're
their castles their locations we're
familiar with I think that's why they
went with us and you can't go wrong with
Game of Thrones - I want to talk about
some of the cast we have apparently led
by Naomi Watts and this actor Josh White
House who is pretty much a newcomer but
now we have kind of this slew of
fresh-faced cast is there anything off
the bat that you kind of see where
you're like I can see where this is
going or anybody to think it might be
relatable first of all I just want to
say I love the fact that they are mostly
all unknown actors because that's what
they did for Game of Thrones right
launch these actors into superstardom it
wasn't right away but these people I'm
sure their twitter feeds are blowing up
right now yeah and Jamie Campbell Bower
was from he was one of the Valtteri in
Twilight that's how I know him but that
is the handsome devil I'm all in for him
yeah and I think we were discussing yeah
what we think it might be we think he's
a little bit of a Targaryen he Jeff
honey he looks like um what's Danny's
brother's name
Viserys yes serious yeah yeah a little
little little Viserys there and what
about Naomi a key Star Wars Episode nine
Star Wars update of a throne you know
what's funny is when I saw this cast I
was like okay so half of these people
are gonna be in Star Wars in the future
because all the Game of Thrones people
go on the cast in the UK there
you know I mean come on what a nerd win
for Naomi aqui thrones in the same year
and I'm looking at Josh White House hmm
I think that right there I'm putting my
money down the chips on the table I
think that's brand available I was just
about the exact same thing I was like
I'm getting a little bit of like the
John Snowden it's dark vibes he looks a
little bit like bran oh who brand of
course is named after I'm really
thinking that's bran the Builder owes
well if we aren't going strictly by the
fire and blood plotline a little bit of
spoilers out there if you have not read
it it initially tells of the egg on the
first who was called the Conqueror he
conquered all Seven Kingdoms set for
Dorne
but he actually ruled alongside gotta
love those Targaryen sand they're incest
his sisters as his queens and he had his
older sister and his young sister so it
could be that Naomi Watts is playing his
older sister and Denise go as his
younger and those could be along with
Jamie Campbell Bower are three Targaryen
looking to conquer okay if that is true
here's where you hurt at first dan wait
it out so what is the what is the number
one thing you guys want to see from the
shelf look there's thousands of
thousands of years to play with the Age
of Heroes so I want to see you know
Garth greenhand start a house garden but
he might be actually bran the Builder
might be related in bran the Builder
helps Duran who built storms end and
it's and it could build on built I want
it all to get up towards the long night
mm-hmm
then I can coming down or not
necessarily the night king but the
others coming down I want that era to
really be mine well and I love that you
said the long night because right now
that is the rumored title Martin himself
has referred to this prequel series as
the long night of course I'm sure HBO
will want to work in Game of Thrones :
and the long night exactly I got a
throne story exactly but no I'm excited
I'm excited that it's such a diverse
cast well and one of the things that I'm
excited about is I want to meet these
new houses that eventually got wiped out
during the conquest and that kind of
laid the foundation for these other
lords to take over these different lands
so like hi Arden was originally the
garden house yeah house garden and and
they're they're gone and then you got
yeah Duran gods grief over he's the one
over storm sent now legend has it he
marries the daughter of the god of the
sea the goddess of wind you know and
say no me watts you know I love your
theory but Naomi Watts could be a
socialite with a secret right oh yeah
what we're hearing what a first secret
is oh I'm a child of the gods you know
it could be anything like that or
Georgia Martin could be saying hey it's
more normal than the legends told and
it's just this power and politics at
play
everything's are established and built
you know I don't know George liked to
work magic in them so we passed all out
over all thoughts can are we okay with
us Oh ash let me tell you something we
are definitely okay Leanne are Galera i
we are so okay with this ask me after
Game of Thrones ends and I'll let you
know my real answer but right now I'm
okay with this I gotta say I was like
really hoping for a Robert's rebellion
thing but now after talking with you
guys I am more okay with it but we want
to hear from you guys let us know
whether or not you're okay with the Game
of Thrones pre goal what's the number
one thing you want to see guys thank you
so much for joining me ken what are you
working on I'm working out a lot of
things I'm always talking into
microphones you can follow me at kidnap
suck and I got my new Game of Thrones
podcast cast early talk coming out soon
as we build up to season 8 I can't
believe I'm not ready I'm not in game
watching shape yeah and we in have some
exciting things coming up I'm sure dude
the return of Westeros weekly will be
cutting back as Game of Thrones final
season approaches in April's get excited
I'm Ken we'd love to see you come by I'd
love to be back your copy is really good
thank you thank you thank you guys so
much for watching and we're okay with it
[Music]
you